how tall are you i'm six four six five
six five man
you're i know you're very see but i need
steroids because you see a guy like me
i'm i'm six five i weigh 189 pounds
like like what do you weigh i'm about
245 250 but
yeah ripped unless if you're in you know
some type of sports that kind of
back then demands it there's no real use
for it really well does it look good
um if you just want to look good but i i
really don't
don't recommend it yeah i get in a fight
with a guy your size let me get my ass
kicked
yeah i would recommend not getting into
that fight
in your book by the way is this all
worth it is the book selling like crazy
this is like a national phenomenon
what's going on here i really didn't
know
how this book was uh going to influence
not just baseball but it's influencing
everyone in general but the players have
got to be pissed because they got it
because now they go
to mcguire must be on fire right the
only way to make this completely valid
and i believe eventually will happen one
of these players will come out of the
woodwork and agree with me listen
my attack is not towards a player
players my attack
is solely and strictly against major
league baseball
and the player association are they
calling your records into question then
they might as well call
everybody's into question right um
i don't know how they're going to do
that because in in the 80s and 90s
it was it was the steroid error and what
i'm saying is
if they're you know throwing you out and
and casting aspersions on you
right then they have to do it to
everybody right well i don't know i
don't know if they will or they can
because i'm the only one
or one of the very few is admitted
taking steroids my main objective was
never to attack the players my main
objective was to attack major league
baseball and player association
the reason why i named the players is
because i need these individuals to come
out and admit to what i'm saying is the
truth
um so what is wrong with major league
baseball and the players association
they are loud star wars in the game they
endorsed it they they turned their
you know blind eye to it and because
they were all
uh you know betting benefiting from it
financially
so you're saying like like even in your
book you said you worked for a george
bush our president he used to run a
baseball team and you say even he turned
his head towards steroid use right
at the time when i was being traded to
the texas rangers an article came out
saying that you know jose canseco
obviously
you know brought steroids to the game in
a sense
uh whether educating players or by
you know physically showing them what
what he can do with it
and uh you know i i just kind of
elaborated on that
you're saying this is no big revelation
absolutely not no
i kind of know that people do steroids
well you look at these people and you
say well
why do they look that way aren't you a
little shocked that congress even cares
like like seriously
why is congress worrying about baseball
for when they got to worry about you
know the whole infrastructure the
country's falling apart
i mean i don't care what baseball
players do i honestly i ask that god
don't care
i i think because nowadays it's a social
problem really i think
people don't understand that i mean
there's so much pressure to succeed in
sports
right especially with the salaries in
baseball nowadays i mean
a player has three or four good years
and you're making 20 30 million a year i
mean that that's just incredible
and the pressure to perform and perform
on a daily basis the schedule is 162
games long then you got spring training
which another 30 games and you got
playoffs in world series
so you're looking well over 200 games i
mean that's just a lot of pressure
a lot of wear and tear on the human body
let me ask you something though
are there pl not every player takes
steroids no absolutely not not every
player not every player
no but you do get an advantage if you if
you take them right because you get
stronger
um i for myself the major advantage was
maintaining my strength and my stamina
during the whole year right that's
definitely
right because your recovery time impact
that's why you see a lot of athletes
let's say um you know pre-steroid error
you know these athletes would maybe buy
by the all-star break which
i mean back then 20 30 years ago if you
had 30 home runs you were a god
right right yeah you hit 30 home runs
you're looking for a job are you still
taking uh
you got all this stuff you still juicing
i don't take illegal drugs though no
no well you take the legal ones what are
they not
no i think people have to go back to my
high school
and i kind of talked about this in the
book where i mean i wasn't the most
you know genetically gifted gifted an
individual i mean i
had back problems i remember one time
coming home from high school and just
bending over being paralyzed on the
ground for half an hour
wow so uh i mean i've had four major
back surgeries i've had
uh we're constructive elbow surgery hand
surgery
and for me in general and i don't and i
don't endorse steroids in any way shape
or form i think it's
it's very dangerous especially for young
kids i mean they're illegal
uh if you're gonna do them which i you
know i don't recommend it for everyone
but you've got to have some type of
medical supervision knowing about the
body i mean i'd rather people be
informed about steroids and
and growth hormones then go in a dark
alley with you know
some used needles some infected needles
and
some steroids that are you know
basically purchased in the black market
you don't even know if they're steroids
or not
and just injecting these massive dosages
yeah it's dangerous tell me something
dub
do you think players who use roid should
be allowed in the hall of fame got to
right
yeah you have to i don't see how they're
going to
change i don't know that's the most
difficult course because i don't see how
they can judge
will they keep you out of the hall of
fame i have no idea
you don't care i care obviously right
but it's out of my control
okay how do you let a guy who's taken
steroids for a long time into the hall
of fame
how do you take if say barry bonds has
taken them how do you take his career
and compare it to hank aaron they're not
the same careers not comparing
they didn't play on the same field you
know what i mean they played in a
different way how do you compare records
one guy got stamina from steroids the
other guy did you don't have to compare
records
that guy didn't do everything it took to
be the champion
no come on he was it's illegal he wasn't
allowed to in a hundred yard dash if i
trip the guy next to me i've done
everything i can to win
people are going to be debating this for
a long time